[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 la
emisión de esta ocasión es un homenaje
para la campeona por la igualdad
ruth báder ginsburg que quien falleció a
sus 87 años tras 27 años al servicio de
la corte suprema de eeuu y después de
toda una vida consagrada al derecho con
enfoque de género
ginsburg fue honrada en la corte suprema
y también en el capitolio antes de
llegar a su morada final en el
cementerio nacional de arlington en
virginia su partida dejó convulsión
política a pocas semanas de las
elecciones presidenciales pero también
bases firmes para continuar la lucha
contra la discriminación jueza de la
corte suprema- heroína de la lucha
feminista opositora declarada del
presidente de donald trump
ruth báder ginsburg fue una de las
mujeres más influyentes de eeuu educada
con una premisa de mujer se
independiente y lo cumplió aquí una
muestra de lo que fue su vida
o sea que estés caminante en exceso
una pionera del siglo 21 ruth báder
ginsburg fue para muchos estadounidenses
una estrella de rock magistrada del
tribunal supremo y heroína de la lucha
feminista hizo de su espíritu
independiente una marca de identidad fue
una estudiante brillante en la facultad
de derecho de harvard cuando casi no se
admitían mujeres en las universidades
fue una de las nueve que estudiaban
entre 500 hombres se graduó de la
universidad de columbia como primera de
su clase pero aún así ninguna firma
quiso contratar la siendo mujer judía
madre de un bebé de cuatro años sus
aspiraciones eran inusuales para la
época y esa discriminación se convirtió
en la especialidad de harvey y como se
la conocía en 1972 cofundó el women's
rights project una asociación para la
defensa de los derechos de la mujer
dos años después la organización
participó en más de 300 demandas por
discriminación sexual derecho al aborto
licencias de maternidad discriminadas
caso por caso
game bird se volvió una leyenda
con su enfoque tranquilo y conciso sentó
las bases legales para la igualdad de
género en eeuu y en 1994 bill clinton la
nominó como jueza de la corte suprema lo
que la convirtió en la segunda mujer en
ocupar un cargo en el más alto órgano
judicial estadounidense en la década de
1980 la balanza de la corte suprema se
movió a la derecha siendo ginsburg una
de las pocas voces progresistas en una
corte conservadora una octogenaria
potente que nunca se saltaba a sus tres
sesiones deportivas por semana flexiones
pasos planchas y un apodo que recuerda
sus luchas
notorious arbey y en referencia al
rapero estadounidense notorious big
iniciales que luego se convirtieron en
un libro y en un documental dedicado a
su vida la revolucionaria ginsberg
enfrentó en su vida cinco episodios de
cáncer y una operación cardíaca en 2014
nada de eso la detuvo para ir a trabajar
no
y está con nosotros lo re interesa
abogada principal de intercontinental
law firm y miembro de florida bar el
organismo rector de abogados para el
estado de la florida hoy analista para
conversar del impacto que causó la vida
de ruth ginsburg en la vida de las
mujeres en ring bienvenida a ellas hoy
muchísimas gracias por la invitación
lorraine un paso a la vez eso decía
ginsburg en lo que muchos trabajan
llamaron a un trabajo lento pero
constante sin embargo yo le quiero
plantear esto y es que la lentitud no
necesariamente sería un sinónimo del
trabajo de guinzburg cambios
estructurales no suceden en un día y
esta mujer en una generación nos cambió
la vida a todas las mujeres
especialmente dentro de eeuu pero es
algo que tiene incluso alcance
internacional usted qué opina
totalmente o sea el legado que ha dejado
la huesa es para todos no solamente para
los eeuu para el mundo
siendo la segunda mujer en servir en la
suprema corte de justicia siempre luchó
por la igualdad de géneros y luchó
porque decía que los hombres y las
mujeres tenían que ser tratados
igualmente que todos fuéramos iguales
bajo la ley y eso es algo que trasciende
no solamente los eeuu en el mundo entero
mire y algo muy llamativo de la historia
de harvey
es que siempre destacó la presencia de
un hombre a su lado como pieza
fundamental de su ejercicio del
feminismo ella siempre hablaba muchísimo
de su esposo y de lo valioso que había
sido que él no la viera como competencia
sino que al contrario el ánimo en una
época en la que no había protagonismo de
parte de las mujeres nos demuestra esto
entonces que el feminismo necesita
trabajar con los hombres para producir
cambios contra la discriminación
totalmente totalmente yo creo que eso
fue un apoyo fundamental en toda su
lucha que el apoyo de su esposo siempre
al lado de ella y motivando la para que
siguiera adelante formas sencillas de
mostrar que la lucha de la igualdad no
tiene que ser
y que tampoco necesita de los gritos
hablaba mucho ginsburg de que su madre
le enseñó a ser una dama y una dama para
ella era una mujer que no necesita o
buscarse para probar sus argumentos y
bueno esto fue algo que vimos a lo largo
de su historia y de su carrera cuando
empezó a ganar casos por las mujeres
desde los años 70
así es ella fue trabaja antes de llegar
a la suprema corte de justicia y trabajó
mucho tiempo con la unión americana de
libertades civiles y ahí cuando trabajo
como directora de los derechos de las
mujeres en esa institución ganó cinco
casos ante la suprema corte de justicia
todos buscando igualdad
para las mujeres y ya luego de eso entré
a la suprema corte de justicia y sigue
trabajando por esa igualdad en la que
ella cree y ha dicho
hay muchos casos que ella obviamente
hizo estuvo en la mayoría en la suprema
corte de justicia uno de ellos pues un
caso de un instituto militar en el
estado de virginia donde ellos no
aceptaban mujeres la excluía porque eran
mujeres y en una en ese caso ella en la
mayoría dijo que no que tenían que
aceptarla porque ya estaban eran
calificadas
otro caso también en el cual ella hizo
en este caso estuvo en la parte de la de
disentir pero igualmente igualmente fue
un caso valioso fue el caso en el cual
ella por un tecnicismo ante la suprema
corte de justicia tuvieron que
desestimar el caso
en un caso de igualdad para el pago
salarial de hombres y mujeres ella
ahí no pudo hacer nada pero sin embargo
le tiró la bola a la cancha del congreso
diciendo que diciendo que era el momento
de ellos actuar y así fue en el 2009 el
congreso pasó una ley bajo el gobierno
del presidente barack obama en el cual
se requería que hubiera igualdad en los
salarios tanto para hombres como para
mujeres
en sus últimos años de vida harvey y
empezó a ser conocida como the notorious
arbilla y se le empezó a comparar con
una estrella de pop y esto bueno tiene
un trasfondo muy importante cuál es la
historia detrás de esta forma de
nombrarle la jueza estadounidense mira
es inspiradora es esperado ahora porque
es emocionante ver como jovencitas las
seguían estaban inspiradas por ella
y que te digo es un legado un legado
para los eeuu definitivamente y bueno
qué bueno que llegó a conocerse a sí que
la juventud llegó a conocerla porque
hace poco sacaron una película sobre la
vida de ella
interesantísima les recomiendo a todo el
mundo que la vea el que no la ha visto
y es es impresionante como la juventud
ha conocido de ella y como como nos ha
ayudado todo en un tiempo tan divisivo
ahora mismo en los eeuu de tanta
dimensión tanto social como política
tenemos mucho que aprender de su legado
un uno de sus mejores amigos fue el
también fallecido pues antoni scalia y
tenían opiniones totalmente diferentes y
sin embargo pudieron tener una amistad
hermosa es como te digo es si es un
ejemplo eso es una inspiración para
todos nosotros y hablando de un plan un
poco más personales de la jueza lorein y
de su historia de vida siempre hablaba a
ella de ser mujer que es igual a ser
independiente y hablando de ese plano de
ella pues conversemos sobre estos
desafíos que tuvo que enfrentar a lo
largo de su vida fue una mujer que
enfrentó el cáncer desde muy pequeña con
su mamá después con su esposo después
ella misma sobrevivió a cuatro episodios
de cáncer y falleció por complicaciones
de ellos entonces nos da un ejemplo
ginsburg de que se puede trabajar y se
puede continuar un ejemplo de superación
y también un ejemplo de mucha valentía
nunca faltó a trabajar siempre que su
salud se lo permitió así es
impresionante o sea una mujer de
avanzada cuando entró en la universidad
tenía una niña pequeña
el esposo sufre de cáncer y a todo esto
ella iba a las clases de su esposo
tomaban las notas de la clase del esposo
volvía a la casa se las llevaba estaba
en el logro de la universidad de harvard
quien en ese entonces ella una minoría
como ustedes bien saben de 500
estudiantes solamente habían 9 mujeres
siendo ella una de ellas tomaba o sea
atendía al esposo trabajaba escribía
para él los reviews estaba estudiando
ella misma
atendía a la niña o sea impresionante es
una guerrera
qué legado nos deja arbey y hoy en día y
cuáles son los temas en los que aún
tenemos que seguir trabajando porque uno
de los grandes temores de sus seguidores
es que con su fallecimiento pues se
cambia la corte constitucional se vuelva
muchísimo más conservador es el supremo
de los estados unidos
qué hay que hacer ahora bueno está
difícil es ahora mismo un momento muy
difícil en los eeuu
todavía estamos en un momento sombrío
para todo lo que creemos en la igualdad
en los eeuu vamos a ver qué sucede si es
que pueden confirmar un juez
antes de que se terminen las elecciones
estamos muy cerca de las elecciones y no
sabemos qué va a pasar pero creo que lo
más importante es seguir defendiendo lo
que ella defendía y una de las cosas que
yo defendiera la acción afirmativa en la
cual es una acción que fue entablada en
los eeuu para superar la discriminación
racial en los eeuu ella siempre decía
que ella fue favorecida por eso y fue
muy favorecida muchas mujeres por eso
incluyéndome a mí porque en este en ese
momento entrar a la universidad las
mujeres tenían un cupo muy muy muy
limitado y gracias a la acción formativa
muchas mujeres podemos entrar a la
universidad
y podemos ser hoy en día la escuela de
derecho tienen la mitad de los
estudiantes son mujeres y un tercio de
la población son jueces federales
mujeres en los eeuu o sea que esperemos
que podamos seguir en ese mismo en ese
mismo camino para honrar su memoria
llegamos al final del programa gracias a
usted por estar con nosotros y por este
ejercicio de memoria que esperemos que
perdure por muchísimo tiempo muchísimas
gracias por la invitación y ya para el
cierre solamente un recordatorio citando
a ginsburg las mujeres pertenecemos a
todos los lugares donde se toman
decisiones siga con nosotros en france
[Música]